what's that like what lessons have you
learned about leadership and maybe about
yourself as a human being from this
first
uh almost a year soon to be a year as a
ceo of this incredible this complex this
large company oh i saluted question let
me let me answer in reverse order um
first thing that i learned um and i i
think is probably common uh
across ceos especially uh in our
industry is it will be great if i had
more time uh
i think there's
especially because we're growing so many
areas and there's so many things to
learn so many uh relationships to build
uh time to spend with a number of
different technologies and
and but it kind of reflects really the
size of the opportunity that exists for
qualcomm qualcomm it is really growing
in a number of different directions all
at the same time
and uh so it did got busier um and uh
part of this is because i'm spending a
lot of time understanding the new
industries we're going in and building
uh
relationships second thing which is a
lot to do with how i think about things
and a little bit of my personality
at the end of the day
business partnerships really done by
people
and i think the importance of having
trusted relationships for the long term
uh is extremely important and i've been
dedicated to do that as ceo we're not a
company that plays for the short term we
don't and when we build new partnerships
we expect that to be for decades and
so i i spend time doing that and i think
that's important for qualcomm the other
part of
your question is
we do have a lot of opportunities in all
different areas what we like
and i've been fortunate enough to become
ceo at a time
that a lot of the trends are pointing to
our technology we talk about some of
them we talk about merger of physical
and digital spaces we talk about the
transformation the automobile we talk
about the merge of computing
and mobile
the enterprise transformation of the
home there are many of those trends and
those trends create opportunities for
qualcomm
to be
providing technology first
and as such we're in a hurry
so i'm in a little bit of a hurry
because i think the opportunity is
incredible for technology but uh
but having fun and and enjoying the job
is there a burden because of so much
what you said is uh partnerships and
you know almost like friendships
connections with other human beings
uh me as an introvert that has a lot of
social anxiety
that seems extremely stressful so is
there that burden on your shoulders you
have to wake up every day
and talk to
friends you've had for many years
it could be you know and then convince
them
and make partnerships with them
talk with them describe to them the
future sell them an idea and then
yourself grow because you don't know
what the heck the future is going to be
like and you have to project both
confidence and humility all those kinds
of things is that exhausting
um
it is exhausting but it's something i i
do like to do and it's it's not only
with partners really it's also
internally to your employees so i think
to get alignment on the vision and uh
and faith in the vision and execute and
at the end of the day we're very
fortunate we have a lot of smart people
so people when if they're aligned with
the vision they know what to do
and and then of course as ceo you have
to convince your investors that's that's
the right idea as well
you